i had just recently worked with ash on
music videos together and we just hit it
off and she's
brilliant i mean she is so talented and
smart
and i am so excited for people to be
able to see
her on screen we heard your news
juilliard and congrats that's
incredible you're thinking of my sister
b she's going to julia next year
this movie gave me creepy feels
it felt like black swan in a way
what would you guys say the message of
this film is
i think the message well it depends on
what you take away from the film
i think that if you see it as
you sacrifice a lot for what you want
or you give so much of yourself
to your passions that it's almost as if
you're
killing yourself in a way sure because
life is a bad balance
and julia this is that balance how would
you
describe it so people can get excited to
watch this
yes so nocturne is a about a young
pianist juliet
at a prestigious art school and she
discovers
a journal of a recently deceased
classmate
and starts to study it and learn it
and it kind of takes over her life and
pushes her to do the worst
and overtake her sister after school
sydney you kind of mentioned um the
lengths that people will go to
for their passion what is the craziest
thing that each of you guys
have done uh to get where you are today
or
for a role crazy i mean
just getting your parents to come here
is pretty crazy on its own
because i feel like we both moved like
across the country because where are you
from again
i've been spoken washington yeah and i'm
south carolina so we literally both made
the giant trek
across the country i did lock myself
in like a crawl space before to prepare
for an audition
wait really what audition it was a long
time ago it was a play the younger
version of amber heard
john carpenter's movie reward
and so i locked myself in a crawl space
and told my parents don't come get me if
i start screaming did it
help where they're cycling i mean i was
terrified but the whole election was
literally me having
terrified so i was like how do i terrify
myself have either of you guys
experienced i mean i know that your
characters are sisters in this movie
but experienced like a mean girl moment
in hollywood
i feel really lucky as far as like i
feel like i've always been surrounded by
just the greatest
people um i mean there's obviously a
couple
bad eggs here and there like there are
everywhere but i
i do feel like i've been extremely lucky
as far as like
everyone surrounded in our world at
least that's good to hear
you were like yes
i mean girls or girls i i'm more scared
of moms
hungry no that's that's a real thing
that's a real thing
i saw a mom trip a kid walking out of an
audition voice
are you kidding me no and we wonder
where the kids get it from you know
sydney euphoria got some love at the
emmys
zendaya took home the best lead actress
award
have you had a chance to congratulate
her to
celebrate with her i mean we've all
endlessly sent her
congrats texts calls all of that and
we're all so very very proud of her
how does that sort of up the ante for
the cast as a whole
as you guys go into season two i mean we
we definitely have a lot to
like live up to right now and fall off
for season two but i
i know that everyone's gonna be really
amazed by what we have
how does season two sort of compare
to season one i mean we've seen that you
guys are back on set
literally i can't say anything about it
but it's somehow
more messed up than season one it goes
places but i did not know that we could
go
yeah your new show with halsey i'm so
excited for you guys it's called the
players table
how did this project sort of come about
and how do you feel about people
shipping you in the comments they're
like so obsessed with your
friendship that you guys have and i'm
just curious about all things you and
halsey
well ash is amazing so about a year ago
i
really wanted to start a production
company and i just didn't know where to
start and
i was like i want to find properties to
be able to produce and so i started 50
50 films and i started getting sent some
books that hadn't been released yet
and my agency sent me it used to be
called the players table and then they
switched the names so they wish they
were us and they released it a couple
months ago and
i read it a year ago fell in love with
it met the author jessica goodman
and she somehow believed in me enough to
be able to take her baby
and shop it around to different places
and
i met with jean-marc ballet who i worked
with on sharp objects i
i presented this book and my idea of
creating a limited series with it and
he was completely on board and i had
just recently worked with ash
on the music videos together and we just
hit it off and she's
brilliant i mean she is so talented and
smart
and i am so excited for people to be
able to see
her on screen and just the length that
she's going to be able to go
and i sent her the book and i was like i
don't know if you want to act
or if this would even be something
you're interested in
and she loved it she called and we had a
whole like team meeting
and that's how it all happened
[Music]